[APPLAUSE]
ADAM KUCHARSKI: OK.
Thank you.
It's great to be here.
Thank your for the invitation.
My name's Adam Kucharski.
I'm a searcher specializing
in the mathematical modeling
of infectious diseases
and, as well as that,
a writer most recently of this
book about the relationship
between science and gambling.
Now, on the face
of it, my day job
couldn't really be further
from casinos and plastic chips
and playing cards.
But actually, the relationship
between science and gambling
is quite a close one.
The two subjects are
actually very intertwined.
And that's what I want to talk a
bit about today-- a few stories
and examples of how lonely
people have taken ideas
from science and math and
used that to take on games
of chance, also how many
gambling games and betting
situations have inspired
a lot of the concepts
and are fundamental
to modern science.
What I want to do is
start with lotteries,
because for me it was
lotteries-- a story
about lottery,
actually-- that first
got me interested in the math
of betting several years ago.
Now, I'm sure any of you who've
looked at the lottery or play
lottery will know it's
incredibly hard to win.
But the way in which we
measure how hard it is to win
is a fairly recent development.
Although mathematics
goes back millennia,
the ideas behind measuring
probabilities of event
is something that only
really started to take off
in the 16th century.
And it was actually a person
called Gerolamo Cardano, who
was during the Renaissance
in Italy, he was a physician.
He was the first person to
describe the clinical symptoms
of typhoid, for example.
He was also one the first
to describe games of chance
mathematically.
And what he did is outline what
we now know as a sample space.
So this possible
space of events.
And obviously, if
you want to know
the probability of
an event, you just
hone down on the
particular one of interest.
So for a lottery, the
UK National Lottery,
you pick six numbers
from a possible 59.
There's just over 45
million possibilities
there, which obviously gives
you pretty poor odds of winning.
But there's a way
of guaranteeing
that you can have
a winning ticket,
and that's simply to take
a brute force approach
and buy out every
single combination.
Now, that might sound
a little bit absurd,
but let's just stick
with it for a moment.
For the UK lottery, each
ticket cost 2 pounds.
That's an outlay of
about 90 million pounds,
if you're desperate
to guarantee that you
have the winning ticket.
Clearly that's not realistic.
However, not all
lotteries are the same.
And in the 1990s,
the Irish lottery
had a much smaller sample space.
And in fact, there were about
1.94 combinations of numbers
that you could pick.
Each ticket was 50 piece.
So actually, it would cost
you under a million pounds
to buy out every
single combination.
And this is what a
syndicate spotted.
And they thought, well,
this is plausible now.
This is something we could do.
So they got a hold of tons
and tons of blank tickets
and, by hand, filled
out every single one
of those possible combinations.
Now, if you're going to spend
a million pounds to essentially
buy the jackpots, in
most weeks, the jackpot
is going to be maybe
a few thousand.
That's a pretty poor investment.
You're spending a million
to buy maybe 400,000 pounds.
But if there's a
rollover, potentially you
come to a situation where you've
got a positive expected value.
You would actually, if you
have all these tickets,
gain a profit.
And that happened in the
May bank holiday in 1992.
The rollover reached
about 2.2 million pounds.
The syndicate put their
lottery strategy into action.
They went around with all
these tickets from location
to location, going to shops
that maybe would normally
sell 1,000 tickets and going
in and asking to buy 15,000.
Lottery obviously twigged
what they were doing,
and despite the fact that
it was completely legal,
somewhat frowned upon it
and tried to stop them.
So in the end,
unfortunately, they only
managed to buy up about 80% of
the combinations of tickets.
Luckily for them, that still
included the winning ticket.
Unluckily, that week, there
were two other jackpot winners.
So they had to
split this jackpot.
But when you added up all
the lower-tier prizes,
they actually walked away with
a profit of 300,000 pounds.
Now, for me, that
was a great example
of how you take a pretty
simple mathematical insight,
a good dose of
audacity and hard work,
and convert it into something
that can be profitable.
Now, in this situation, it
was just a brute force attack.
Essentially they just went
for every single combination
to get the jackpots.
That's pretty simple
mathematically.
That's not particularly
interesting.
But if you delve down
into lower-tier prizes,
things get a little
more intriguing
from a mathematical
point of view.
At the other end
of the scale, say
you want to guarantee
a lottery that you're
going to match one number
in a particular draw.
Obviously all you have
to do in that case
is just buy out tickets with
all the numbers in sequence.
You don't have to buy many
tickets to make that work.
How about two numbers?
Well, for the old National
Lottery in the UK,
where you pick six numbers from
a possible combination of 49,
people working in
combinatorics have
showed that the
minimal set of tickets
you need to guarantee
matching two numbers is 19.
So this is known as lotto
designing in combinatorics.
If you want to
match three numbers,
however, that's
an open question.
Actually, nobody's
worked out what
the minimal set of
tickets you need
to guarantee matching three is.
Some people attacked
it numerically.
So they just run through
and crunch through and learn
possible combinations.
And the lowest of
what I could find,
at least, was somebody who
came up with 163 tickets
to guarantee matching
three numbers.
But actually, it's
an open question
as to whether there's
a lower set out there.
So there's a lot of interesting
math even in lottery,
which on the face of it seems
like a pretty trivial problem
to work on.
But it's not just
modern mathematicians
working these kind of problems.
As I said, people like
Cardano, throughout history,
have been interested in it.
And many of the big
figures in maths
have also worked on
games and gambling.
This gentleman, for instance.
This is Henri
Poincare, really one
of the great figures
in around 1900, one
of the few mathematicians that
the last mathematicians really
to work in every
field of the subject
as it was when he was alive.
And one of the things he was
particularly interested in
was predictability.
So this notion of
unexpected events.
And he categorized it by what
he called degrees of ignorance.
For him, unexpected
outcomes were the result
of ignorance about the causes.
And he classed this three
levels of ignorance.
He said the first
one is a situation
where what the rules are.
You have the information.
You just need to use elementary
calculation to get the answer.
So if you do a high
school physics exam,
this is kind of the
situation you're in.
You know what the laws are.
You have the information.
You just need to do
some calculations
and ideally get
the correct answer.
The second level of
ignorance Poincare
said is something where you
know what the rules are,
but you don't have
enough information
to make an accurate prediction.
And he used roulette
as an example.
He said, in this situation,
because you got a roulette
ball going around a
table, a very small change
in the initial speed of the ball
can have a very large effect
on the outcome.
Now, this idea
subsequently developed
into what's known as
sensitive dependence
on initial conditions.
In the '60s and '70s, became
one of the central components
of chaos theory, popularly
known as the butterfly effect,
the sense of dependence, the
idea that a very small change
in a weather system
in one location
can have a very large
effect somewhere else.
So it's not necessarily
a random system.
It's just that these very small
imperceivable changes early on
can have large effects.
And then we say,
according to Poincare,
that those are due to chance.
But that wasn't
where he stopped.
There was also this third level
of ignorance he focused on,
and this was a situation where
you don't know the rules.
The rules are so complex
you can't pick them apart.
And in this, all
you can hope to do
is watch enough
realizations of the system
and try and gain some insights
into what might be happening.
Now, when mathematicians
and scientists initially
start tackling roulettes,
they focused on this level.
They didn't treat it
as a physics problem.
They treated it as
one of observation.
Let's look at a lot of
roulette spins and try and look
for something unusual.
See if there's a bias
in the table, something
that we can exploit.
This raises the
question, though,
of what do we mean by odd,
what do we mean by a bias.
And actually, while Poincare
was in France thinking
about roulette
tables, in the UK,
Karl Pearson, the
statistician, was also
thinking about roulette.
And to him, we can never
really have any sense
of the true process in nature.
We can only analyze
what we can observe.
And because he wanted to
understand randomness,
he needed to generate a
phenomenal amount of data,
because this was what he
wanted to hone his methods on.
In fact, he once spent
his summer holiday
tossing a coin 25,000
times to generate
a random data set to analyze.
He was also interested
in roulettes.
Unfortunately for
him, at the time,
the "La Monaco" newspaper would
publish the results of roulette
spins in Monte Carlo Casinos.
And for Pearson, this
is a perfect data set
which you can analyze in
terms of what's going on.
And the first thing
he looked at-- so
we take a roulette table.
You've obviously got these
black and red outcomes, and then
this zero.
And if you remove
the zero, you'd
expect black and red
to be about 50-50.
And in his data, I think
red came up about 50.15%
of the time.
So based on what he had, he
said, this isn't implausible,
that this difference
is kind of acceptable.
But then he started looking
at pairs of numbers.
And obviously, if you're
doing a lot of roulette spins,
you'd expect sometimes
by chance to get a string
of the same color appearing.
But in the data,
Poincare noticed
that the two switch too often.
You didn't get these strings
of the same color appearing.
What was happening was you'd
get black and red switching
more than you'd expect.
In fact, he said that, had
he been watching these tables
since the start of
geological time on Earth,
he wouldn't have expected to
see a result that extreme.
Pearson actually, in the end,
was quite angry about this.
He thought that Monte Carlo
were rigging all their tables,
wrote a lot of angry
letters, in fact,
suggested they
should be closed down
and the proceeds
donated to science.
But there was something
else going on.
As it happened, those
journalists at "La Monaco"
weren't actually
sitting by the tables
and recording all the numbers.
They were instead
sitting in the bar
and making them up, which
explains what was going on.
But these ideas that
Pearson honed and have
become an important
part science--
think back to that sentence.
The probability of
observing an event as
extreme as the one
we observed, given
that he said it was random.
That's the early
foundations of a p-value.
This is a statistical test.
And so whether in
my line of work,
where we do things
in clinical trials
or you're testing any kind of
hypothesis, all of this theory
originated with Pearson
throwing coins and looking
at roulette tables.
And as well, these
kind of theories
have been applied by gamblers
to understand roulette tables.
In the first half
of the 20th century,
many gamblers would actually
watch the tables and instead
of sitting in the bar
and collect the data
and look for biases.
And when you had tables
that were worn down
or certain areas of numbers
were appearing more often
than others, they used
this to capitalize and have
an advantage over the table.
Over time, casinos worked
out what they were doing
and made sure that the
tables were incredibly well
maintained and shouldn't exhibit
any noticeable bias over time.
But in the '60s and '70s, a
number of physics students
realized that this puts you
back in the second level
of ignorance, that if you have
an incredibly well maintained
table, you can essentially
treat it like a physics problem.
One of them compared it to
a planet orbiting a point.
You should be able to write
down the system of equations
governing that process and solve
it given enough information.
And the '70s in
particular, one group
at the University of
California, Santa Cruz--
it's quite a well-known story.
But what they did was divide
up the spin into what happens.
Initially, it starts with the
ball going around the rim.
Often it would go
around a couple times
before the croupier
calls no more bets.
You've got a window where
you can obtain information
and capitalize on it.
Then it would drop
down onto the track,
spin freely, and then eventually
hit one of these deflectors
and end up in one of the slots.
And what they realized is
that actually, in this system,
if you collect enough
information over time
and calibrate your model
to the particular table,
that initial period of the
ball going around the rim
gives you enough
information to be
able to make not perfect
predictions but certainly
enough to get an
edge over the casino
in terms of where
the ball will land.
That's all well and good
doing that in a classroom.
But if you want to
do it in a casino,
these aren't calculations
you can do in your head.
You need a way of
computing them.
So they designed
wearable computers,
wearable hidden
computers to carry out
these calculations in a casino.
And as it happens, the
first ever wearable computer
was designed for this purpose.
So a huge amount of
wearable tech now.
This is where it all originated.
Obviously, they had
some teething problems.
They quite often
get electric shocks
from their computer,
which is not ideal
when you're trying to keep
a low profile in a casino.
In other situations,
this sensitivity
to initial conditions
came to play.
Like if the weather change,
for instance, they'd
need to recalibrate their model.
Another occasion, the
team started losing money
and couldn't really work
out why until they realized
that further down there was
an overweight guy leaning
on the table and screwing
up all of their predictions.
But in many cases,
these ideas stimulated
a lot of thinking about
these kind of process.
And the research didn't
become gamblers necessarily.
Many of them went into
technology or finance
or academia.
But they treated it as almost
a playground for ideas.
It was a way of just testing out
this problem-solving ability.
And interest in
games and gambling
has continued from an
academic point of view.
One example is poker and games.
Obviously, there's
a lot of interest
in AI around game-playing
algorithms now.
Poker, as it happened, was
one of the first inspirations
for game theory.
Back in the 1920s,
John von Neumann
was a brilliant mathematician.
He was the youngest
professor in the history
of the University of Berlin.
Wasn't so good at poker, though.
And on the face of it,
poker is a perfect game
for mathematicians, right?
You've got a probability.
You get dealt a certain hand.
You've got a probability
your opponent gets
dealt a different one.
But of course, reality is a
bit more complex than that.
And as von Neumann
said, real life
consists of bluffing, of
little tactics of deception,
of asking yourself, what
does the other man suppose
I'm going to do?
And trying to
understand this push
and pull between
different strategies,
he looks at some very
simplified versions of poker.
And he started off, for
example, with two players.
Each of them dealt
a single card.
They both put some money
in the pot at the start.
And then the first player has a
choice of either just sticking
with their existing
money in the pot,
and then they
compare their cards.
Or this first player
can raise the stakes
and see if the
other player reacts.
It's a very simple game.
Von Neumann observed
there's essentially
a tug of war going on
between these two strategies,
because each player
is simultaneously
trying to maximize what they get
and minimize their opponent's
payoff, because in a
game like poker, anything
your opponent wins comes
out of your pocket.
So you're trying to
really push and pull
between these two approaches.
And in the middle, there's
an equilibrium point
where neither player
will have anything
to gain by unilaterally
changing the strategy.
So if you're familiar
with game theory,
this is kind of the early
ideas of a Nash equilibrium,
the situation where
neither player over time
would expect to gain anything
by changing what they do.
When he analyzed this very
simple version of poker,
he found that if the
first player gets
dealt with a high card,
it makes sense for them
to raise the stakes.
Intuitively that's
pretty obvious.
If you have a good card,
good chance of winning.
If you've got a middling
card on that draw,
you haven't got a great
chance of winning,
so you don't want
to up the stakes.
In this case, it makes
sense to stick with what's
already in the pots.
Interestingly, though, when the
player was dealt a low card,
this equilibrium
strategy said that they
should raise the stakes.
And if you think
that through again,
it kind of makes
sense that, if you've
got a low card, if you
stick with what's in there
and just turn over
your cards, you
haven't got a great chance of
converting it into a victory.
The only way you
can profit is to try
and scare your opponent out of
the pot by raising the stakes.
Now, at the time, poker players
had obviously implemented
things like bluffing.
This was a common
tactic, but it had always
been seen as one
that was more a quirk
of human psychology
than something
that was a mathematical feature.
But this was
essentially von Neumann
proving that bluffing
is a necessary part
of these kind of games.
Essentially, he constructed
a mathematical proof
that bluffing is a necessity in
these kind of games of chance.
The strategy in this very
simple version of poker
is what's known as
a pure strategy.
There's a set of fixed rules
of, if this happens, do this.
If you get a high or low
card, you raise the stakes.
If you get a middle card,
you stick with your bet.
And many games have similar pure
strategies that you can follow.
So anything that has
perfect information--
something like
noughts and crosses
or checkers or chess--
in theory has a strategy,
a fixed set of rules,
that if you follow them,
you will get the optimal
result every time.
The challenge, particular
things like go,
is obviously finding
those kind of strategies.
And sometimes they
might be intractable.
But in theory,
there's one there.
There's a whole class of games
that that doesn't work for.
So one obvious example
is rock-paper-scissors.
It might be admirably
consistent of you
to always pick the same one.
But if your opponent works
out what you're doing,
you're clearly not going to
gain much in the long run.
Really what you want to
do is alter the choices
you make to make your
opponent's decisions as
difficult as possible.
So for rock-paper-scissors,
it doesn't
take much to spot that the
way to make your opponent's
decisions as hard as possible
is to simply pick randomly
between these three options.
And so over time,
if you do that,
you wouldn't expect
to lose on average.
For a simple game of
rock-paper-scissors,
that's pretty trivial to spot
that that's the strategy.
Obviously, for poker,
there's a vast number
of different combinations
you could have,
and the situation
becomes far more complex.
It's not something you can just
write down a neat solution for.
And actually, one of John
von Neumann's colleagues,
called Stanislaw Ulam, was
interested in these kind
of questions.
He wasn't a typical
mathematician
in that he didn't
really enjoy trudging
through lots of equations.
On one occasion, his colleague
found him solving a quadratic
on a blackboard.
And when he got
to the end, he was
so exhausted and bored that
he went home for the day.
[LAUGHTER]
So really that wasn't
his kind of thing.
He was once playing solitaire.
He was playing Canfield, which
is originated in casinos.
And he wanted to work
out the probability
that, if you lay out
the cards, you have
a situation where you can win.
And he quickly realized
that actually trying
to write down all the
combinations that that would
involve is just a bit arduous
and what would be better
is instead just to simulate a
few times-- lay out some cards,
see what happens.
At the time, with
von Neumann, he
was working at Los Alamos
on the nuclear projects
and looking at
neutron interactions
inside the early developments
of hydrogen bombs.
And again, it was
a similar problem,
where you had a lot of random
interactions of something
that's very hard to
solve analytically,
and it made more
sense to simulate.
Because they were working
on a government project,
they needed a code name for
this new kind of method.
So as Ulam had a
heavy gambling uncle,
they nicknamed it the
Monte Carlo method.
And this has now become a really
important part of science.
We use it in disease analysis
for things like Ebola and Zika.
The transmission dynamics
are incredibly complex.
It's not necessarily something
you can solve mathematically.
And it makes its way into
a number of other fields
as well, including
analysis of games.
Many of the top
game-playing algorithms
now use these kind of
simulation-based approaches
to refine their strategies.
And in poker as well, one team
at the University of Alberta
adopted this kind of approach
and refined their strategy
so much over time
that, last year,
they announced that
poker is solved.
So for two-player poker, in
which the potential stakes are
limited-- so known
as limit poker--
they had essentially,
through this kind
of iterative approach,
found a situation
or a set of strategies which
are such a good approximation
to the equilibrium that it
wouldn't expect to lose money
over a kind of human lifespan.
So they hadn't found
this exact solution
like we can write down
for rock-paper-scissors,
but they found one which was
such a good approximation
that they wouldn't expect
to lose money over time.
It's obviously a
tremendous achievement.
But it does have the
limitation that you're assuming
that your opponent is perfect.
If you design an
equilibrium strategy,
you're assuming you're facing
the optimal potential opponent.
And that makes it
quite defensive,
because essentially you might
be facing someone with flaws.
And if you're following
the equilibrium strategy,
you're essentially
deciding that you're
trying to minimize your losses.
You're trying to make sure that,
no matter who you're facing,
you're not going to
lose money over time.
Of course, people do have flaws.
And just to illustrate what
happens when people play
games, what I'd like
you to do is just
pair with the person next to
you and play a couple of games
of rock-paper-scissors.
So I'm sure you all know how
this works-- one, two, and then
show what you do.
So just a couple of games
and see what happens.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
ADAM KUCHARSKI: OK.
So I think everybody's
had a go at it.
OK.
OK, great.
So there were a few
of you, I think,
who were playing a best
of seven or something.
But what I'd to
do-- OK, so can you
just raise your hand if, on
your first go, you picked rock.
OK.
Who picked scissors?
OK, and who picked paper?
A lot of people
didn't play, it seems.
[LAUGHTER]
So generally-- I
don't know if you
can see that-- but the
split there was most
people were picking
rock or scissors.
And actually, in many
large-scale games
where people played a lot of
times, that tends to happen.
Papers isn't a very
popular opening option.
And often what will
happen is novices
and particularly
men will pick rocks.
So it's not that a
hard and fast rule.
But that's generally
what happens
is scissors comes out as
the most popular option
amongst experienced players.
So I told you about
five minutes ago
what the optimal strategy
was for this game.
And yet, you kind of still
fell into certain patterns.
I think as well between what
happened between your first go
and your second go.
So in one large
study done about two,
three years ago,
what tended to happen
was the person who
won on the first go
would stick with the same
one on the second go.
And the person
who lost initially
would switch to the move
that would have beaten them.
So if you lost to rock, you'd
switch to papers afterwards.
So again, doesn't always happen.
But people often will
fall into these kind
of predictable patterns.
There's actually a
story about 10 years ago
where the head of an
electronics firm in Japan
wanted to sell an
art collection.
And Christie's
and Sotheby's were
interested in
holding the auction.
And the head of the
electronics firm
decided the fairest
way to settle
it was with a game of
rock-paper-scissors.
Now, Sotheby's were like, great,
that's random, that's fine.
Christie's, however,
he had a daughter--
the CEO of the company--
who played it relentlessly
at school.
So he got his
daughter to teach him
the basics of
rock-paper-scissors strategy.
And sure enough, they
walked in to play this game
of rock-paper-scissors.
Sotheby's treating it randomly.
Christie's with a strategy.
Christie's walked
out the winner.
Because in these
kind of situations,
if you're viewing it as
a completely random game
and you're playing this
[INAUDIBLE] opponent,
it makes sense potentially
to deviate from your strategy
and take advantage of that.
But there's a
downside in these kind
of games if you try and
adapt what you're doing.
If you move away from
this equilibrium strategy
to try to exploit an opponent.
And that's what's
known as the get
toward an exploited
problem, because if you've
got a very smart opponent,
they could teach you
a false appearance of
what their strategy is.
So in poker, they
could initially
pretend to be quite
passive, maybe indecisive.
And you would adjust your
model of your opponent to that.
And then they would
adapt their strategy
and take advantage of
the fact that you've
learned an incorrect
version of themselves.
And there was actually an
example not just with poker.
In other industries,
you have this problem.
So finance is another
situation where
big increase in the
role of algorithms,
unlike poker, where you have
these very detailed strategies.
In finance, obviously if
the aim is to be quick,
you want as little
code as possible.
You want to execute
it as fast as you can.
And a couple of years
ago, there was a situation
where two Norwegian
traders had noticed
that a US stockbroker had an
algorithm which would always
react to a trade
in the same way.
So no matter how
big the trade was,
the algorithm would
change the price
by exactly the same amount.
So what they did
is they trained it.
They got it, made lots of small
trades to nudge up the price,
and then made a huge one and
profited from the difference.
Now, that went to
court, obviously.
And they were charged
with market manipulation.
And they were handed
suspended sentences.
But on appeal, their
lawyer made the point of,
if they'd been trading
against a stupid human,
there wouldn't have
been anything wrong.
The issue that apparently
was the problem was they
were trading against a
stupid algorithm, who
presumably was
designed by a human who
was lacking in a few skills.
[LAUGHTER]
And that appeal was seen
as justified, actually.
It didn't make sense that if
you're trading against a human
there should be different
rules for if you were
trading against an algorithm.
How can one be skillful
and yet the other not?
And similar arguments have
developed in other fields.
For example, a few
years ago-- and
is continuing to happen--
that the US are cracking down
on poker, particularly online
poker but also real games.
And in 2011, a person who was
offering a poker room in New
York was actually taken to
court for operating a gambling
operation.
Now, in federal law,
many casino games
are explicitly
defined as gambling.
But poker isn't
actually one of them.
So poker is kind of
open to debate a bit
as to whether it is gambling.
And in federal law,
gambling is defined
as a game that is
predominantly down to chance,
predominantly the
result of chance.
So this whole legal
case rested on,
is poker predominantly
a game of chance
or predominantly
a game of skill.
A lot of economists
and mathematicians
weighed in, obviously making
the point that in a single hand
you got this element of luck.
But over a realistic course of
a poker game, skill can prevail.
And this is actually the first
time that a judge in the US
has ruled on whether poker is
predominantly a game of chance
or a game of skill and ruled
that it was a game of skill.
It was not gambling
under federal law.
But there's a footnote to this
case, because under state law,
gambling is defined
as anything that has
a material element of chance.
Now, it's very hard to deny that
poker has an element of chance.
And so in this case, it
was defined as gambling
under state law, and this
decision was overturned.
And then you were
seeing it increasingly
with things like fantasy
sports as well in the US.
Where do we draw this
line between something
that's a chance and
something that's skill?
And I think there's
often this temptation
to almost put things in boxes.
We like to say, this
is a box full of luck,
this is box full of skill.
And I think this also tends
to, if we're good at something,
we tend to put it in
the box on the right.
And if we're bad at something,
we put it on the box
on the left.
But really, I think, history
and looking at these games
and gambling has
shown that it's much
more of a spectrum than that.
Some of the stories
that I've shown you
and many other situations
and things like card counting
as well have shown that a
lot of games that maybe we
think of luck actually with
sufficient skill and efforts
can be overtaken with
mathematical and scientific
thinking as well.
And actually, games that we
think of purely dependent
on skill perhaps may have
an element of luck as well.
So back in the '90s, when
Garry Kasparov was playing Deep
Blue, IBM's chess computer.
There was a point in the
game where Deep Blue made
a move that was by all accounts
so ingenious and so subtle
that it threw Kasparov a bit.
And actually, a lot
of the commentators
said it changed the
course of the game,
because it was so unusual what
he had done that it convinced
Kasparov that he was playing
something that was simply
beyond what he had
encountered before.
He was playing an entirely
new class of player.
As it happened though, Deep
Blue hadn't chosen that move
because it was clever.
It had run into
a situation where
it couldn't make a decision
about which move was best.
And in that situation,
to avoid a dead end,
it had been programmed
just to pick randomly.
So this game, which
is really held up
as one of the landmarks
of artificial intelligence
versus humans, one of the
most significant moves
was actually made
purely by chance.
So again, games of
skill potentially
might be closer to
luck than we think.
And I think that's why gambling
is a really interesting field
of study, even if you never
visit casinos or bookmakers.
I think whatever
industry you're in,
gambling and betting
and chance play a role.
I mean, I work in health,
in business, and finance.
The situations where we have
to try to make decisions
with hidden information.
We have to try and
deal with uncertainty.
We have to try to balance risk
against potential payoffs.
I think historically
that's what has
been so interesting
to a lot of people
who are quantitatively minded
and continues to do so today.
But I think there's
another reason as well,
which is why these games
are so interesting.
And I think Alan Turing
put it well when he
was working on
games to understand
thinking machines a bit better.
As he said, it would
be disingenuous of us
to try and disguise the fact
that the principal motive
for the work was
the sheer fun of it.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
We're now opening
up to questions.
I have the first
and obvious one.
Do you gamble?
And how many casinos
are you banned from?
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM KUCHARSKI: Actually,
I mainly play poker.
And I think one of the things
this book has kind of taught
you is how many games-- just
the sheer amount of effort
required.
So there are syndicates
out there taking
on a huge amount of sports.
But essentially, that would
just be doing my full-time job
on a different data set.
So I think poker's a nice one,
where a relatively small edge
can play quite a big role.
Unfortunately,
most of my friends
refuse to play with me now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
Kasparov and Deep Blue.
And we've just had-- or
we-- DeepMind and AlphaGo.
What's your opinion
on the work that you
see DeepMind doing in terms of
changing games from-- rather
far more to the scale element
and kind of the way computers
are working on games?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: I
think one of the things
with Go that stands
out, and it's
similar with poker,
is just the speed
at which these
developments are happening.
So I think Go for
a lot of people
was safe from computers
for a few more years
and, similarly, with a lot
of the more complex forms
of poker.
So no-limit, hold 'em,
and these kind of things.
I think people had this
idea that humans would
be dominant for a lot longer.
So I think that's quite
interesting in the time scale.
Also with Go, just the
way it's tackling it,
because obviously it's
a game that you can't
find this optimal solution.
So from what I
understand, it's much more
about understanding
the shape of the board.
So adopting almost
more human approaches
to learn these games rather than
simply crunching the numbers,
as you might do for
a very simple game.
So I think that's quite
interesting of having
to reproduce human
learning techniques.
And actually, for poker,
a lot of the algorithms
they use to try
and solve these are
based on regret minimizations.
So they have a kind of regret
function within their learning
component.
So I think that's actually quite
interesting, just coming out
as a side issue, of what the
efficient ways of learning
these kind of games are.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
this works in the
disease spreading part,
and if you tried that
with any diseases,
like maybe Zika or something?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: Yes.
So as I mentioned,
many of the ideas that
came out of games and
gambling we use in our work.
So an obvious example is things
like Monte Carlo simulations,
that generally if you try
to infer what disease does,
you need some way of
combining a simulation
process with inference of data.
And so actually, in
this kind of situation,
it's much more efficient to
just do lots of simulations
and then kind of refine
them to what the data is.
But there's a number
of other ideas as well.
So in some situations,
people using game theory.
Again, these kind of strategies
that came out of betting to
understand how different
countries may be interacting
to make vaccine decisions.
Because in many
situations, you have
almost like a tragedy of
the commons, from something
where you've potentially got a
vaccine that has a side effect
or has a problem.
From an individual
point of view,
your priorities and
your risk profile
is very different to
what a population does.
So if you have a whole
population making a decision,
you might have some
effective herd immunity.
But if enough
individuals ignore that,
you can end up with
a different outcome.
So it's the push and
pull between what's
good for a population and
what's good at individual
and how those things interact.
So I think that's where a
lot of the ideas come into.
I think it's also just
good sometimes when
you're working with
these ideas day in, day
out, to understand
where they come from.
And I think as well just the
fact that these kind of games
are very nice situations.
If you work in disease
data, it's pretty murky.
There's a lot of unknowns,
a lot of uncertainty,
whereas for something like a
simplified version of poker,
it's a sort of well-defined
problem to work on.
So I think you do
in any industry,
you work on kind of
cartoon problems,
because they're
simple to analyze.
I think it's just
interesting to see
how the history has developed
in these kind of things.
AUDIENCE: The disease
data, I'm quite interested.
And we hear a lot about
immunization-- sorry,
the way that antibiotics
will affect us
on a global population and
that we might not globally
be prepared for outbreak
of a pandemic or similar.
And that often feels like
it's a governmental problem--
governments communicating
with each other and so forth.
So as a mathematician,
as a scientist,
how do you look to
communicate your findings
onto a kind of political
and to a human level
and try to impact the system
that is often quite messy?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: That's
a good question.
Doing Ebola, we did
quite a lot of work
with government agencies.
And I think one of the things
they say is it's better to be
80% right today than 90%
right in two years' time.
And it's really kind of
working on-- there's never
a single piece of research
that defines a policy.
It's always that
kind of aggregation.
But I think there's
often situations
that there's a lot of options.
It's not clear what's
even reasonable.
I think modeling and a
mathematical approach
is a good way of essentially
taking things off the table
and refining it down.
I think, especially doing these
kind of real-time outbreaks,
the Zika's another example.
There's a huge amount
of uncertainty.
And ideally, you'll get in and
do all kind of field studies
and do everything properly.
But in the absence of that,
we need to make decisions now.
I think these kind
of analysis are
quite a useful way of doing it.
I think policymakers
appreciate having things
there very quickly as an
evidence base to make decisions
on.
AUDIENCE: I was just thinking
about your [INAUDIBLE] a bit
like roulette moving from
more into a skill mode
than a luck mode.
Do you think the insurance
industry is actually
going to be-- because
at the moment,
it's just down on
this huge population,
and you're roughly
going to die or roughly
going to have a car crash.
But actually, as you have
increasing levels of data
about everything you do in a
car or every bit of genetics,
then it becomes
calculable potentially.
Do you see that shift in
the insurance industry?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: Yeah.
I mean, it's already happening.
I don't know the
details, but I know
there's been a few test
cases in recent years of that
trying to refine it
into certain parts.
So the split between males
and females, for example.
And I think there's
been some legal disputes
as to whether you
can actually do that.
And you're right.
It makes sense if you had
that large set of data,
because you can really
refine the risk based
on a particular individual.
But there's that kind of
conflict between people
wanting a uniform policy.
So again, that's the
kind of interesting thing
of where what the model says
is best conflicts with what's
actually acceptable.
AUDIENCE: So if
you've got an opponent
that you know is playing
a perfect strategy,
is there any way to use
that information to game
that opponent?
And are there some games
which are, because of this,
intractable?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: So if you're
playing a perfect opponent,
then I suppose by the
definition of that strategy,
your best response is to play
an equilibrium strategy as well.
One of the things that's
interesting, actually,
talking to people who are
working these poker games
is, in two-player
situations, it's
pretty obvious that, if they're
playing an optimal strategy,
you need to do the same.
But the definition of an
[INAUDIBLE] equilibrium
is on unilateral behavior.
So it's no player has anything
to gain by individually
changing that strategy.
But when you have
multiplayer games,
you have the potential for
collaboration and coalitions.
And actually, some of the people
working on poker, particularly
on the versions of the
game that are intractable,
have found that you can have
these kind of equilibrium
strategies.
And when people
put them together,
potentially two players
could gang up on a third.
And the third can't do
anything about that.
So in that situation,
where they all
are playing pretty
good strategies but not
perfect ones, it
doesn't necessarily
make sense for that person
who's being picked on
to rely on that as a defense.
And it might make
sense to look for flaws
in what they're doing instead.
So I think there's
just a lot more
to be seen for when you
have these multiplayer
games, that it's not so clear
that these kind of equilibrium
strategies are useful.
Hopefully that answered your--
AUDIENCE: It did, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm very
curious as to what
brought you down that path.
Why did you write this book?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: So I've
said, these kind of stories
have always been hovering
in the background for me.
And it was actually,
it was during my PhD--
so I did PhD in maths.
And we'd often get emails from
usually the standard crowd,
just tons of investment
banks, generally.
But you'd often get a few
different ones appearing.
And it was actually
firms who are essentially
betting hedge funds got in touch
about possible recruitment.
And for me, that was
something that I just
wasn't aware of as an
industry that had developed.
And actually, as you
start to look into it,
it was only in the
last decade or two
that in the UK on, say,
football that people
have been able to
make consistently
good enough predictions to make
that a viable business model.
And that kind of started for me.
That was quite interesting.
That was something
I was completely
unaware of as an industry.
And then when you start to
dig down into the history,
you realize that
not only there are
a lot of other people doing
these things that potentially
aren't reported a lot.
Actually, you've got a lot
of quite major developments
in science that-- I
don't know about you,
but I was just
completely unaware
that a lot of these ideas
had originated with games
like roulette and gambling.
I thought it would just be
really interesting to have
a book that explores not only
the history but also some
of the modern efforts and,
again, with some developments
in AI.
I think that's coming
on frustratingly almost
when you write a book, that
it's coming on so quickly,
because it kind of updates.
But I think that's
fascinating looking at what's
happening in the modern day.
And it's just the
fundamental question of,
if you're going to put money
on the line, what evidence
do you need to make a decision?
And it's the same of whether
you're deploying a vaccine
or whether you're making
a business choice.
It's what evidence convinces you
that that risk is worth taking.
I think gambling is a
really interesting industry
to look at in that context.
AUDIENCE: So we work
at Google, and we love
data sets and big data sets.
We had a speaker
recently who spoke
of understanding whale
noises and that it's
a problem where, if we
had a larger data set,
we could actually make some
progress trying to understand
how they speak to each other.
So in terms of your industry
and what you're dealing with,
what would be your
fictional ideal
big data set that currently
you can't collect or is
too expensive to collect
and you would love to play,
be it a game or
health or similar?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: So in
terms of my day job,
I think one of the big questions
that we don't know-- generally,
we focus on things we
can measure easily.
You know, a disease
case is been diagnosed.
That's the thing.
If we for Ebola put
in a treatment center,
that's something
you can quantify.
I think the thing
that's really hard
to measure is
behavior and attitude
and how they change
during outbreaks.
And I think they change a
lot, particularly for Ebola.
We see it in some areas,
the epidemic would tail off.
And anything you could shove in
a model would not explain that.
There was clearly some
feedback process happening,
and people were seeing what
was going around and changing
their behavior accordingly,
and I think just in reaction
to a lot of other
of these outbreaks.
And that's something
that's quite hard to--
I think often we try to
measure stuff as proxies.
You can do surveys of
people and their behavior.
But if I ask you what
you're doing today
and there's a huge
outbreak next year,
can't guarantee you're going
to behave in the same way.
And I think that's
something that
would be really interesting
to try and understand actually
what people really do versus
maybe what they say they do
or what they think they do
and how that has an effect,
because I think that's a
big gap in our understanding
of outbreaks certainly.
AUDIENCE: In the
beginning, you were
talking about the group that
found the hole in the lottery
system.
Did you, while doing your
research for the book, also
find some fault, some flaw
in a system that you could
have potentially exploited?
ADAM KUCHARSKI:
So one example is,
if you remember back in January,
the UK National Lottery.
So they introduced this rule.
So they upped the
number of combinations.
So I think it was
previously about 9
million possible combinations,
and they upped it
to 45 million.
And unsurprisingly,
this meant they
didn't have any
winners for ages, which
is incredibly bad
publicity, because actually,
for lotteries,
they like winners.
It gives them people
smiling with checks.
It's good.
An interesting rule-- if it
hit 50 million as a rollover,
they would redistribute
the prizes to lower tiers.
So that was one thing
actually I sort of chatted
with a few people about,
of in that situation,
if you don't necessary have
to win the jackpot to net 50
million, that gives you
a positive expectation
on the lottery.
So actually, the value
of a ticket on average
is worth more.
But then there's
the issue of, is
expectation of good way
of judging an investment?
Because you've got a tiny,
tiny chance of winning a lot.
And then again, from
ideas from the book,
if you actually looked at
that kind of investment,
if you looked it from
a utility point of view
rather than, if I played
this game an infinite number
of times, I might make a
profit, think of it of,
how much is this worth to me?
How big a bankroll do
I need to make it worth
buying a 2-pound ticket.
And actually, in that case,
with these kind of lottery
rollovers, buying
a single ticket
is only worth it if you're
a billionaire, basically,
from a utility point of view,
which is not a great message.
But I think there was a lot
of focus on people saying,
well, you know,
it's expected value.
It's a great week to play.
But the nuance of actually how
do you make those decisions,
I think, was a quite interesting
thing to think about.
MALE SPEAKER: You're talking
about obviously the strategies
for playing games
and stuff but also
in relationship to banking,
investments, and stuff.
Obviously, that's an area where
different people are competing
with different strategies.
But as soon as one strategy
starts to take hold,
then that changes the
environment in which
the strategies are behaving.
So are there any
interesting things
happening in trying to predict
not only when you introduce
a strategy and how
it will do, but how
it will change the environment?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: Yeah,
that's a very good point.
And that's one thing that
people are starting to work more
actively actually
is-- I think there's
a lot of focus on finance from
an individual point of view.
You've got a single
investor, a single strategy.
But of course, it's
basically an ecosystem.
And a few people compare it
to an evolutionary dynamic,
that if you come up
with a good strategy,
other people adopt it.
And then it becomes
less successful,
and then you have to kind
of evolve what you do.
And they're saying the
bigger the advantage,
the quicker it's going to decay
in terms of effectiveness,
because it'll be easier
for people to spot.
And I think for these
high-speed things in particular,
that time scale is quite
short, because if you speed up
what you're doing, you have such
a big edge over other people
that there's a big incentive
for them to come in.
And in one case, for
example, the people
are building a
hardwire from-- I don't
know if you heard about this--
from London to New York,
underneath the flight path,
because it would give them
a fraction of a second quicker
information on the market.
And building that cable
is sufficiently valuable
to actually get that edge.
So I think in
particular, as the speed
increases, that evolutionary
process is increasing a lot.
And I think there's a
lot we don't understand.
I mean, you can take
some of the basic ideas
from ecology, about what happens
when you put lots of people
together.
And one of the classical results
actually from chaos theory
in the '70s was, if
you have something
following simple
rules, it can do
very weird, complicated things.
I think we're seeing similar
things in finance, that you
have a load of algorithms
written with 10 lines of code
sitting together, and
they don't necessarily
do what you think they'd do.
So I think that's quite an
interesting, important field,
but one that hasn't
been fully explored.
So it'll be nice to see
what happens in the future.
AUDIENCE: Going back a bit
to the disease outbreaks,
you mentioned that that data
is sometimes not complete.
So I was wondering, where do
you usually get that data?
And once you get
the results, how
does that data turn into action?
Do you just give it
back to the government?
How does that work?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: So it varies
depending on the outbreak.
I mean, so with Ebola
and these kind of things,
ideally you have
data on the cases
as they're being
collected at the time.
We're working directly with
agencies as well as WHO.
You had Medecins Sans
Frontieres, and these kind
of groups and actually kind
of converting the data back
into a potential
forecast for them.
So I think with
all these things,
it kind of works best if
you work with the people who
created the data, because they
understand how it's collected,
and it's potentially useful.
But I think one
of the things that
was surprising with Ebola, for
example, is that in many cases,
people collecting
data in one district
didn't actually have the
data for the next district.
So we had a situation
where we were synthesizing
it and visualizing it
and giving it back,
so they kind of knew what
the border picture was.
And it's quite a
basic data analysis,
because it's essentially just
cleaning it and visualizing it.
But I think in some of
these situations, that's
almost the most important
thing-- that you
can do fancy modeling
in the long term.
But really the fundamental
thing on the day
is, what's the situation?
Is this the kind of idea of
nowcasting for a disease?
You're always looking
into the past,
because you have
these delays in terms
of how the data come
through and under-reporting
and those sort of stuff.
So the data that comes
in today might actually
be representing what
happened a few weeks ago.
So even just making
those adjustments
and giving them back to
the people in the field
can be quite a useful exercise.
AUDIENCE: You've discussed how
in chess, Go, poker, roulette--
these kind of
games-- there's been
sound kind of breakthrough
in which someone could
be pretty much all the others.
What kind of game do you see
next, where this could happen,
where somebody could
develop a new strategy
or get more data than anyone
else and beat the system?
ADAM KUCHARSKI: So which
game might fall next?
I think poker,
certainly no limits.
We're kind of at that point.
So there's a
tournament last year,
where bots kind
of played humans.
And they played a vast
amount number of hands.
The humans came out with a
very slightly smaller pot
on average.
So naturally the
researcher said that
wasn't statistically
significant and the human
said that they had won.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think we're reaching
that point where,
if you talk to professionals,
these games are still safe.
If you talk to the guys
working the algorithms,
it's only a matter of time.
And I think it's
particularly interesting we
have these strong feelings about
games that are seen as an art.
So a lot of these
poker kind of games
are scene as very
experienced players
with intuition and instinct.
I think that's their realm.
So it's quite interesting as
computers start to come into it
and challenge those notions.
So yeah, I think that's
going to be the one to watch
in the next couple years.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
If there are no more questions,
I think we'll wrap it up here.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you, Dr. Adam
Kucharski, for being here.
It was a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]